hey guys welcome back to your weekly
data stream recap and today was kind of
jam-packed with a lot of information
kind of like upcoming ideas and patches
that they're coming out with but the
results some other stuff but anyway
let's get right into that and we'll talk
about it right now so first on the list
the newest weekly content has been out
and it's for combat emotes which I'll
show to you guys right now so enjoy
[Music]
you
[Music]
those are the combat emotes those are
going to be costing you guys 7,000 each
so if you do want those go pick them up
next up is the public test is not live
for all you PC players I don't know how
many of you have subs to me but for the
few of you that might it is live
progression in the public test will be
lost because players who win tournaments
will be getting ornaments engravings and
tattoos and such and then wouldn't be on
that'd be a bit unfair if they get to
keep it as a test because the console
players wouldn't have that chance
because we don't have the public test
and your stats on the public test are
collected as of June 15th so anything
you did from June 15th until now will
not be in the public test but anything
before then will be so for example if
you were rep 8 at June 15th but now your
characters about 10 it will show that
they are rep key don't worry you're not
losing anything it's just when they grab
it all the data and stats when you go
back and get out of the public test
everything will be normal so don't worry
about it remember this is also for PC
players so console players you don't
have to worry about this revenge gain is
going to be changed eventually in a
future patch and then how revenge works
and all of its stats and all the data
from it will be in a patch in season 3
there's also going to be no more stamina
regeneration on ladders also when you
slide down ladders it's going to cost
more stamina for when you use it instead
of actually hitting someone which is
preventing people from camping on
ladders I do want to preface this though
these are ideas that they are coming up
with that are going to be in future
patches not on the one today will get in
the one that came with today it was a
very simple pass which is the Centurion
well let's continue on next up is when
you respawn you will be invincible from
attacks and guard bricks for 4 seconds
preventing spawn camping for honor will
now display your skill level as higher
lower or even relating to your teammates
and also display the reputation score of
the player and not just the character
you're playing as I'm not sure if this
is only in the duel tournament though
but if it's in the game in general this
might be good for example if you and I
were facing off and you had a rep 20 no
bushi and that was all you played in
your score would be rep 20 but let's say
I have rep 3 warden rep for Ken say my
score would be
seven so your 20 versus my seven it
would show your average score and in
terms of skill it related to your
teammates so if we're in a group of four
and my skills a little bit better than
the whole team it would say your skill
is slightly higher than the rest of your
team or slightly lower or on part it's
kind of to make the teams a lot more
balanced colorblindness is also going to
be guaranteed in the next patch there's
a three other there's three types of
colorblindness they did say I don't know
the exact names I'm not really big on
colorblindness and I am not colorblind
myself but if any of you are be happy
and hopefully it is your type of
colorblindness I know there's tons out
there hopefully it works and hopefully
you can also play the game correctly
next up is in the next patch you'll also
be able to use different emblems for
different heroes so for example if I
have two emblems I can use the first one
on warden and the second one on my Ken
today without having to swap in the menu
ornaments will now be the same color as
helmet material on the next patch and
you'll also be able to match it with
your team color on your outfit as well
it also in terms of colors you also have
more colors to choose from there making
it so that most of the neutral tab is
also going to be fair game for attacking
defense colors as well next up contract
orders are going to be ordered in terms
of difficulty making them easier to find
and choosing which one you want to do
they're also going to be new event
orders involving winning matches instead
of just winning game mode or getting
kills in game modes it's not going to be
winning matches but these are just ideas
that people have come up with next
update they are going to be making a
system for players to get more Salvage
not that we have much already and not
that we have a shit-ton already but
there's also going to be more ways to
spend it such as fast tracking a
character's progression level so for
example I've been playing the Boucher's
you guys have been seeing my gameplay
recently but I'm a very low rep level no
bushi now with the salvage I can
actually use the salvage to gain levels
quicker and get that higher rank faster
is from what I'm taking from this using
Salvage I'm assuming it's going to be a
lot of Salvage because it seems a bit
bit too cheesy but they're also
combining the three salvages from the
faction so
instead of having 30,000 tonight
salvaged 10,000 Viking salvage then like
zero for the samurai you'll have 40,000
in general so it's one type currency now
it's not separated perfection Ubisoft is
also trying to improve the connection
and stability like they always do but
especially on xbox because apparently we
got the worst of it I don't know how but
I guess we do and they're also looking
to make the public test on councils but
not for a while sadly this one isn't
going to be but there's also going to be
tons more public tests they're going to
use and hopefully make it on console as
well and then now for the patch 1.08 or
1.09 version 2 or whatever it's
basically it's a super small patch it's
just changing stuff with Centurion but
he's going to get a nerf today and he's
also going to be getting a nerf in the
next update the nerf for this in general
is his jab in charge jab area-of-effect
has been updated to make the jabbing
tracking less efficient and then making
the punch easier to dodge going
backwards as well as sideways as well
and the felling's
his I hope I said that right before star
feet that gives all players a full
shield the duration of the fee has been
reduced from 45 seconds down to 10
making the phalanx more situational
instead of just throwing it out whenever
he pleases and then that's going to be
the end I know there's a lot of
information I do apologize and it you
probably lost tracker on the whole video
I lost track trying to write down all
the data it was about a minute in 50
second like law or not a minute v it was
an hour and 50 minute long dev stream it
was very long anyway I hope you all did
enjoy sorry if you lost track I do
apologize for that anyway if you did
enjoy like the video if you did dislike
it if you didn't if you knew it hit the
subscribe button for more for our
content my newest for my most recent up
we'll be popping in the top right for
you guys to watch new executions for
shinobi and Centurion you guys do not
want to miss them shinobi 's was
especially brutal so I highly recommend
you check that out as well and then I
will see you all in the next video guys
peace out